I I don't mean to cut you off before you
ask your question but I want to say um
any MMA fighters who uh feel as though
that they could jump in the boxing ring
with a boxer anybody close to my weight
I would love for y'all to jump in the
ring with me and uh try me out car
McGregor try me out any of them I don't
care which one it is uh Cody Crawley
what's the people that's like there's
the guy who's like the Maga dude who's
fighting this weekend Cody kington I
think yeah whatever whatever whoever it
is um that's close to my way I would
love for them to get in R trop me out
well it's crazy cuz the nagana new dude
like he like he held his own like I was
expecting him to get smoked for sure and
that's why I would love to show like it
ain't going to go the same when I get in
there I would love to show like no MMA
fighter could get in the ring with me
and even survive have you had anybody
approach you to do anything like that
cuz it seems like that's kind of the the
thing going right now I heard it was
somebody said that um one of the guys
said my name um what's the guy he be
going back and forth with uh Devin too
um I don't know his name I don't know
his name but uh like I said any one of
them dudes when to step in the ring I it
feels like easy money for you it is for
sure but I just want to show them like
you can't jump in no boxing ring with me
and it's going to go that way I promise
you I'm not going to lie that that yeah
I was a little surprised to see that
that fight went the way it went yeah I
ain't like it I was like damn that's
going to open up the the the can of
worms for everybody to want to come I
felt like it it was
disrespectful um yo so this is the fight
that uh we're we're getting obviously uh
there's been a lot of I mean everybody's
asked you about obviously whenever
you're going to fight Haney is this
going to happen after this fight is
there any sort of progression in those
talks cuz I think we keep hearing about
the negotiations falling through maybe
he he not serious about fighting you
what what is is is that fight ever going
to get made I would love for the fight
to happen um [__] I y'all can clearly
see that I want the fight yeah like
y'all can clearly see I don't know why
like people try to spin the narratives
and like a lot of people good at social
media so they'll turn the narrative into
something else and 30 other people run
with that narrative but um truth be told
I love to fight like I I I fight anybody
yeah um I jumped in the ring with him
for a reason I didn't just jump in the
ring and do that for no other reason
besides okay let's get let's get the
fight started and and is the is what's
off about it still the split I think
what's off about it is his team like I
don't think I think his team is going to
throw anything out there to uh make sure
the fight don't happen um I don't think
that they want the fight to happen right
now um that's what I heard like from
what I was hearing I'm I'm hearing well
that's what it feels like there's so
many weird politics in boxing that I
don't think people understand if you're
just like a generic boxing fan cuz
you're like well this should be easy
like this guy and this guy they want to
fight this is a big money fight there's
a lot of money to be made but sometimes
like you said there's timing yeah it's
business and that's above everything and
that's how they looking at it they see
it as okay why we fight this big RIS
fighter right now rather than wait a
couple of years where we we could make
more money but yeah they could run it
cuz if they lose to you that's going to
[__] up that that might [__] up his bag
yeah and then like like like you know
it's it's almost like what happened with
um for people who are like casual boxing
fans it's like Jake Paul losing yeah is
bad for business yes right so he has to
keep winning so the fact that he lost to
Ty or Tommy Fury is is is uh was was
kind of bad for business yeah but like I
said him and that one dude well his
brother and that one dude uh they they
stirred up some [__] but and that fight
was terrible only issue with it right
yeah if that's the case don't perpetrate
as if you're that's what you want to do
you know you're perpetrating and acting
like that um this is what you want and
um you talking big but truth be told um
you put me and him in a in a ring where
nobody else can help him there's nobody
else that going to be able to fight for
him what's going to happen like he know
deep down the side that I'm the truth
that's what he know he know he done been
the ring with me several times um he go
ask him like really ask him and tell him
to be honest about me as a fighter um
you really hear how he talk and um
honestly I think he's a good fighter but
um I think that his levels